what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 6 of the deep learning with PI
torch tutorials in the last video we
talked about the basics of convolutional
neural networks as well as building our
data set and actually kind of
pre-processing the data set to get it
ready to be passed through a neural
network in pi torch in this tutorial
what we're going to do is actually build
that model and do at least some training
of that model this one's going to be a
little slower just on the CPU so we're
just going to do a little bit of
training and then in the next video
we'll have to talk about how do we speed
that up on the GPU so with that let's
get into it so this was the code from
before I just kind of condensed it all
into one cell just builds the data and
we've got training data accessible so I
just run that real quick make sure yep
okay so now let's actually build the
model itself so we're going to import
torch we're going to import torch CNN as
an end and then import torch dot and n
dot functional as big F now we're gonna
do is class net and again it inherits
from n n dot module and just like before
we have to define an init method and
immediately call super module so a super
init I'm going I own it okay cool
runs that now we're ready to actually
start making our layers so to make our
layers we're just going to do basically
the same thing we did before so we're
gonna say self.com this time we'll say 1
equals n n dot conv 2d and don't forget
to capitalize the C and comp and again
just like before you've got inputs and
outputs and then one more thing so the
input is 1 it outputs 32 convolutional
features and then we have a kernel size
so this is a 5 so this is going to make
a 5 by 5 kernel or window as it rolls
over our data to find features so okay
so so that's our first layer and then
what
do is we're gonna make three
convolutional layers so I'm going to
take this copy paste paste we're gonna
say two and three and just to note these
are convolutional two-dimensional
convolutional layers
Torche I'm assuming has one D and at
least three D but you can use as many
dimensions and your convolutional layers
as you want if it doesn't exist in the
torch you could code it in torch but
interestingly enough convolutional
layers like one-dimensional
convolutional layers so so
two-dimensional convolutional layers
this would be used on images right
images are two-dimensional
three-dimensional is used on like scans
or models stuff like that
and then one dimensional data can
actually is at least recently being used
on even like sequential or temporal type
datasets with a thing called attention
and basically it seems to be
outperforming recurrent neural networks
which were kind of the industry standard
for doing any sort of sequential type of
data so anyways just know there are
other types of convolutional layers it's
not all for imagery but imagery does
seem to be the main Forte of
convolutional layers as well as just
neural networks in general I mean it
seems like most people are using
convolutional layers nowadays so anyway
so we've got our three layers let's make
it a little more interesting first of
all this one takes in 32 we're gonna say
it output 64 that means it takes in 64
and we're gonna say it outputs 128 now
at some point this neural network needs
to have linear layers right it has to
eventually at least output to one linear
layer that would be the the distribution
of predictions right so at least one two
node linear layer we have to get to but
getting to that is actually kind of
difficult and if you just follow the
tutorials on like pi torch I just don't
think they tell you it's this gaping
hole and it was a also a gaping hole in
tensor flow I haven't gone through
tensor flows basic documentation in a
while but also since tensor flow has
adopted Charis Charis has
is literally a flattened function or
method I don't can't remember which one
it is but it has a thing called flatten
and it's super simple in pi torch this
doesn't exist and as far as I could find
researching this there is no good way to
flatten the information so the only way
I know to do this and it appeared to be
this is the only suggestion suggested
way as well
is to actually pass data thorough just
fake data right and figure out what's
the shape so that's what we're gonna do
but if you look for example at this is
an official PI torch example for M nest
creating a convolutional neural network
the main issue is anytime you go from
convolutional layers to fully connected
or linear layers or dense layers you'll
see them call all kinds of things how do
you get the input number because the
input number isn't 50 and then you see
like it's 4 times 4 times 50 where's the
four coming from we don't know where's
the 50 is it coming from up here is it
referencing that 50 what is that
referencing we don't know we have no
idea so so anyway or is it maybe this
five minus this one so four times four
and then like you just you legitimately
don't know but then also these aren't
actually the outputs the outputs come
after you apply a max pooling to the
convolutional layer so is it 2 by 2 so
is it because these are two by twos
there's size four times four I don't we
have no idea we just have no idea so
that kind of sucks I wish they would
explain it better but I feel like they
just gloss over it so how do we get
there so the way that we're gonna get
there is we're just going to start off
by defining some because basically what
we want to do is we want to say self dot
and then we'll say FC one and then that
is going to be equal to n n dot a linear
layer but the question is what the heck
is the input and then the output let's
do 5 12 so it'll just be a 512 dense
layer and then we'll say self dot FC 2
equals and n dot linear this one would
take in 512 and let's say it returns two
because we have
classes so in theory this is our target
for the entire data what would be really
cool as if we could just say negative
one right there like take anything
please but but we can't so at least not
to my knowledge that would be really
cool if we could so how do we get that
number so the first thing that I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna specify x equals
torch Rand and and we're gonna do a
whoops we're gonna do a 50 by 50 and
then we have to reshape or view it as a
negative one by one by 50 by 50 so again
so this is where the 1 these are the
ones that relate to each other so
however many images we have these are
all going to be in there their tensor
form 1 by 50 by 50 so the actual tensor
that we pass through the neural network
will have this exact shape so some any
feature sets we have times 1 50 50
that'll be the input image so okay okay
cool so we're gonna say self dot and
then we'll just say to linear equals
none and then when we win what we want
to do to get this to get to figure out
what the number needs to be to this
layer we have to I'm just going to
comment these out so I can actually run
this first we have to we have to know
like what to pass through here so we
need to run some data through these
three layers and then once we get the
output we can just check the shape and
then multiply the dimensions so if the
dimensions were 5 by 5 by 3 it would be
5 by 5 25 times 3 75 that would be our
flattened shape 75 so what we need to do
is pass some data the way that we're
going to do that is just by creating
some random data and then we're gonna
pass that through self dot-coms X now
we're calling comms comms this is going
to serve as part of our forward method
but not the whole forward method so
we're say define cons self it also gets
X passed and what we're going to say
here
is basically this is just like the
forward method it's just we're only
gonna run forward these three layers
okay so so what we're gonna say is x
equals f dot max underscore pool 2d then
we're going to apply max pull 2d to the
layers so they're doing it a little
different here just for the record so
basically they're saying okay f dot r lu
that's exactly what we used it's kind of
it's the same kind of thing we just did
a rectified linear on the output neurons
basically x' and then here they're just
running max pooling over that output and
then they're just kind of cycling but I
think it to me I think it makes more
sense to put it all on one line but just
know there's many ways that you could do
this we're just applying this function
to the data so max pool 2d and then
we're going to do f dot r lu over self
dot conv 1 whatever X is and then the
shape of the pooling we're gonna go with
2 by 2 so then we're going to do that
for those three convolutional layers
pase pase and then we're gonna do a
quick check so if self dot 2 linear is
is none almost double equals none nice
self dot two linear equals and then
we're gonna say x 0 with dot shape so x0
f dot shape 0 if I want to make sure I
get this right and then time so
basically is going to be yeah so it will
be the zeroeth shape 0 times the shape
the first tooth shape times whoops time
bru times that second value because it's
going to come in with these three values
so so for example cuz x just keep in
mind x is coming in as like a batch of
data so we're gonna say that 0 element
so again it cont this this negative one
denotes hey it could be any size of data
so that's why we're saying zero is so
we're just saying the first one in this
case we're literally only passing really
truly one element but it is a batch of
just happens to be one element so we
pass that through and then we're just
grabbing the shape of that data so so
that sets that value and that just sets
it globally to this object because it's
just self-taught to linear so then all
we're doing now is return X this way and
I'm not leaving this behind yet we're
gonna do some printing but this way we
return X and then we can go and actually
create our forward function or a forward
method rather forward self X and now
let's go what what is going to happen
well immediately we're going to say x
equals self dot coms X because why would
we like we were gonna we would just copy
and paste this code or we could just
call cons right well no reason to copy
it and this won't run anymore because we
set it so one time and we're done
although this this calculation when
wouldn't it be a big deal it really
wouldn't ok so we run the cons and then
we'll just finish this I suppose x
equals x dot view and then we'll say
negative one self dot to linear so we
reshape that to that to be flattened
because after it comes out of those
calms it's not flat yet so not only do
we need to know the number before we
call it here in the initialization which
let's go ahead and do that before I
forget so it's not negative one anymore
it becomes whatever the value of self
dot two linear happens to be so as you
can see right in the initialization of
calling these layers we actually have to
do a quick forward pass to see what's
that number which again is just kind of
lame and I'm sure like I'm trying to
decide like I don't know
what what tensorflow does when you call
flatten but it would just be nice if we
could just do that but anyway okay so so
we need to run that forward pass to
determine the number for here and then
again to determine it here so both
they're both in the initialization and
in the in the real forward pass we also
need to know this number
so then self dot to linear uh-oh so to
you later and then what we're gonna say
is x equals F dot rectified linear over
self dot fully connected 1x so so here
we pass through all the convolutional
layers we flatten it we pass it through
that first convolutional first fully
connected layer pass that through here
and then we still need to pass it
through this final the final one so all
we're gonna say here is self FC - so x
equals self dot FC 2x and then we'll
return X whoo okay so now that we've
done that we are ready to I think well
let's print out a couple of things so
let's print out up here let me print
trying to decide what I want to do for
that I guess here let's just print X
zero so print print X 0 dot shape cool
so we'll go ahead and print that and
we'll actually see the output so what
we'll say is nets equals net
oops what do we got we've got 32
channels expected 32 to 32 okay
I'm actually not positive on this one
let me make sure that ran but I'm pretty
sure did yeah okay three one five five
that's our Kampf I've got 32 channels
wanted oh I bet I know what I do we copy
and pasted here yep this is like hmm
yeah okay so we copy and pasted up here
and we forgot to modify the the values
there that was stupid
okay rerunning that cool so we have so
we can see the shape is a 128 - n - okay
so we can see okay max pooling was a two
- and then it output 128 but then you
know we come over here and in here yet
the output is a 50 so it could almost
make sense but then we look at their max
pooling and it's a two by two so anyway
so as far as I know there's no really
great just like quick and dirty
calculation that we could make to
determine that flatten the best thing
that we can do is actually pass just
past the data and we only need to do it
once so at least it's not the most
beautiful code someone coming from the
main issue is someone coming from a
different library or something looks at
this and it's like wait what
you know why are they running this you
know just really make much sense so
anyway it just makes for ugly code so I
really wish PI torch make a flattened
everyone knows what that means so just
do it please so so anyway and they might
even have a flattened but it I don't
think it would it would apply yet to
just like a layer like in abstract and
maybe that's the problem like maybe
that's why it works on tensorflow
because you define your graph first then
you pass data so because the graph is
defined it's there it could be queried
you know so I don't know maybe it's not
possible but I feel like at least it
would be nice if they would
help us to make this code better-looking
I guess ok that's enough mmm so one
thing I almost forgot is the activation
here so I think I actually made this
mistake in the in the first machine
learning or first deep learning tutorial
so I think it's kind of just a tradition
for me to forget this but in theory you
you probably need some sort of
activation layer here like I said before
though activation layers aren't really
required you don't have to have them it
wasn't really certain like like surely
you could just run these layers because
again it's just a bunch of these vectors
getting multiplied against each other so
so you can do whatever the heck you want
so you actually don't need an activation
layer here but you probably should have
one so rather than just returning X
return like I don't know F dot softmax
we'll go with that
and then again dim one because of the
batches so someone asked before to
please react splain dimensions I really
don't think I can't explain it any
better than I explained it before but
basically the X coming through here so X
here the the X is a batch of X's so how
would you reference the batches like the
batches right would they be so the
zeroeth dimension would be all of the
batches we don't want a softmax we don't
want this distribution across the
batches we want the distribution and by
distribution I mean from 0 to 1 or
really it's more of like a percentage
right we want it to be distributed
across cat-and-dog these these two
things so the 0 with dimension would be
all of the batches the first tooth
dimension would be okay between cat and
dog classifications let's get an actual
distribution of you know prediction
percentage confidence or something like
that anyway cool so yeah one thing I'm
probably going to forget to do it but
try after we do the GPU thing I really
don't feel like testing and showing you
things while we're on the cpu because
it's just kind of slow but later
if I forget return X and fit and train I
can almost guarantee that is going to
work just fine on this problem but on
much more complicated problems it can
help to have activation functions but
especially on the last two output it
probably doesn't actually matter but
yeah
okay so later if I remember too we can
we can remove that and just kind of have
fun because normal networks really are
just a bunch of trial and error like
everybody kind of does a lot of the same
stuff as everyone else but just
understand that nobody knows what
they're doing like truly nobody knows
because nobody understands how neural
networks work so anybody who claims to
be like this you know expert at neural
networks is a dirty liar so so anyway
cool so that's everything we we need so
we actually could start passing data
through and at least to start I think we
could we could do some of this my plan
was to kind of pass information through
and iterate over our data I'm not really
sure I want to stuff that into this
tutorial though because it's gonna be
slow but in the next tutorial I really
want to talk about GPUs so let's go
ahead and throw it in bonus time import
torch optim as Optim and really we've
talked about a lot of this stuff already
anyways so optimizer equals optim and
we'll go with the atom optimizer again
and then again it's net dot parameters
and then we'll go with the learning rate
of 0.001
don't have to explain that or you did it
lost function equals MSE loss yeah the
mean squared error finally so now what
we're gonna do the first thing we need
to do is we have all of our training
data here in this training data
parameter so what we want to do here is
we want to separate out the XS and the
Y's so we're gonna say x equals torch
dot tensor because we want to make it a
tensor and then what we want to do is
reshape all this so we're gonna say zero
because if the we're trying to get just
the X's here so I 0 for I in training
underscore data
and then we're gonna dot view as a
negative 1 by 50 by 50 beautiful then
what we'll do is x equals x divided by
255 again in this task we could probably
get away by not doing that but all we're
doing here is scaling the imagery so the
idea is right now the pixel values are
between 0 and 255 and what we really
want them to be a zero between 0 and 1
so that's how we're doing it
so cool then we're gonna do our Y so
again it'll be just torch dot tensor and
then in this this time it's gonna be I 1
for I in training data okay so once
we've done that the next thing that we
want to do is separate out some training
and then validation or testing data so
the way that we're gonna do that is
first we're gonna grab a valper cent
let's just say zero point one so our
target will be hey let's test against
10% of our data set so Val size will be
equal to the integer of the Len of X so
however much X we have times that valper
so let's go ahead and print vowels this
might take a second cuz we've got this
operation prize what's taking the
longest is just converting this
information but cool so about almost
2500 will be our validation test size
this should all make total sense we're
converting it to an interior because
we're gonna use this as a number to
slice with so it needs to be a valid
index it couldn't be a decimal so then
we're going to have a train underscore
and we'll say capital X here equals x
and we're going to say up to the
negative vows I so this is just basic
Python slicing here so train X train Y
and then this will be test X test X this
will be test y and this will be train Y
and so it'll be y up
to the negative valve size and then here
it will be negative Val size pawn word
negative Val size onward and again just
to make sure print Len train X and then
we'll say prints Len test X okay and
those numbers line up so you know just
in case we did a slice wrong or
something probably a good idea
just to check it one more time so then
we're going to actually train so we need
to determine whatever batch size we want
to use I'm gonna say 100 if you're
getting a memory error
lower the batch size that goes for
really any task at all like if you
download some code off off the internet
the quickest and easiest thing for you
to change if you're hitting memory
errors is the batch size now obviously
you don't want to go down to one it
generally if I can't run more than like
eight in a batch then I'm gonna start
tweaking and decreasing the size of the
model itself like the layers how many
nodes per layer that sort of thing but
the very first thing that you should try
to modify is batch size and then we're
gonna be running on the CPU
so for epochs I'm just gonna say one but
later we'll do many more but then what
we're gonna say is for epoch epoch in
epochs what do we want to are actually
range epochs what do we want to do well
we're gonna say for I in t QT m TQ diem
and we're going to say a range of 0 so
we want to start at 0 we want to go for
the Len of train X so however much
training we have and then we want to
take steps that are the size of our
batch size so I think probably the best
thing is to just print I and then I plus
batch size let me just run that real
quick what the heck for I
what did I do wrong oh okay um range
Tiki diem range zero I just screwed up
my parentheses here this should be the
range function run that again yes okay
so what are we looking at here so these
are going to be our slices through the
actual training data so it'll be so the
first batch will be the zeroeth to the
100th index and then the next batch will
be the 100th to the 200th and so on all
the way through our entire training data
set so that's what's going on there so
yeah hopefully that wasn't too confusing
when my parentheses were off but yeah so
TQ DM is just so we can have a nice
progress bar which would be much nicer
if we're not printing things but I
wanted to print just to show you guys
what's happening and basically yeah we
start at zero we go to the length and we
take steps the size of the batch size so
then well all we have to do is say batch
underscore X is equal to Train X and
then yeah it'll be I : I plus batch size
and then again we want to reshape so
we're save you negative 1 1 50 by 50 and
then batch Y will be equal to Train Y
and then same thing as before I plus
batch size cool so now what we want to
do is we're actually going to do the
fitment so every time you're planning to
do a fitment optimization and all that
you need to 0 the gradients now there's
two ways you'll see people 0 gradients
you're going to have net 0 gradient or
you know like whatever you've called
like an arcades net is corresponding to
our model so you might also see people
use like you know model model 0 grad but
then there's also optimizer optimizer
dot 0 grad so what's the difference well
as long as here so when we ran optimum
in the net
amateurs so all of the parameters were
are being controlled by this optimizer
if that's the case then there's really
no difference between net zero grad and
optimizer does zero grad you could use
either one interchangeably that said
sometimes you're gonna have a model that
actually has two different like it's a
model that's built with two different
neural networks that might have
different optimizers on each side or
something like that or you know there's
gonna be times there at least it's
possible to have multiple optimizers
because you have two different neural
networks that come together to build one
large model if that's the case then you
want to use the specific network in
question so you've got one and you cuz
you could also have an optimizer but in
two different scenarios so it could be
the same atom optimizer but you've got
two you got optimizer one and optimizer
two or something like that so if just
think about your problem and decide
which way do you need to be explicit are
you trying to say hey for the entire
network zero the gradient or are you
saying for just this optimizer or are
you saying you know you just need to
know which is which okay so probably for
most people it's always gonna be just
optimizer zero grad but if you want to
be really specific especially if in your
forward method or in your in your loop
your training loop your training the
whole model together but maybe you're
calling different spots separately or
something like that probably the safest
thing to do is to do a net dot zero grad
but it really is going to depend as long
as you only have one network and one
optimizer for that entire network you
don't really need to think about it
beyond that but just wanted to bring
that up because you're going to see
people doing different things sometimes
we use their model name or sometimes
I'll use the optimizer name and you're
like whoa wait wouldn't should I do what
so anyway NetZero grad either one you
want then what we're going to say is
outputs equals and it's going to be net
batch
X so this gives us our outputs now we
can calculate loss based on what are the
outputs and what were the desired output
so we just we use the loss function
we've defined up here so we can say loss
equals loss function and then it's
outputs and then batch underscore Y then
we're going to loss dot backward
backwards so we're going to apply that
and backward and finally optimizer dot
step and once we've done that we can
actually go and train this model so what
I'm going to do is we're not going to
print anything out and then maybe at the
very end we could print loss print loss
but this is going to take a really long
time most likely we can print loss and
then maybe while that's going yeah so
while that's going we could talk about
like how we could actually we could
predict on the model so so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna say correct
equals zero total equals zero and then
with torch dot no grant also someone
brought up before there is still model
dot trainer so net trained net eval and
at least our case it doesn't really
matter so we don't like have dropout but
if you did you'd want to have everything
activated for when you're actually
evaluating your model will possibly talk
more on that later I didn't even think
about that that was really dumb but of
course that makes total sense that the
same principle applies and like
tensorflow and stuff like that so anyway
there is still a valid use of dot eval
and dot train and you'd want to remember
to switch those on and off if you went
back and forth so now let's just quickly
test all will do this super and
efficiently but that's okay
for int q DM range
of the Len of test X for that what do we
want to do well we're gonna say real
class equals torch dot Arg max test why
I and then we're going to say the net
out is equal to net test X I dot view as
a negative 1 1 5050 and then we want the
zeroth element that would be the net out
now predicted class would be equal to
torch dot R max of net ounce.if
predicted underscore class is equal to
the real class correct plus equals 1 I
really wanted to beat this but I didn't
dang it
otherwise either way we're going to do
total plus equals 1 and then we can
print accuracy round I see the error
there but we'll get there in a second
correct / total 2 3 and then replace
this with a comma
okay let's see what our accuracy is now
is probably nothing good Bulls e 0 how
could that be the case we should have at
least gotten to 50% let me think about
this what did we do wrong for I and T
keep you test X I'm trying to decide I
really can't
I'm not running everything again
test X I should make sure yes there is
something there definitely there was
something there real class test why I
for I test X I output
let's do print real class and let's
print a net out what so test why musts
we must have typo'd yeah oh dear
can I get away with this I wonder test
Wine Train Y was correct we would hit it
error anyway test why I think we we
should be able to get away with just
redefine that come down what is this
disgusting
what am I looking at there oh because of
this okay well we still got to kind of
do that zero okay so now where's my tqt
in I come on I'll get my progress bar
it's kind of weird
where is my progress border oh dear
mm-hmm right as I redid it
apparently it popped up why would the
progress bar take so long to pop up I
wonder hmm
I don't actually know anybody has any
idea why why that would take so long I
don't know okay
now we have an accuracy this video has
been way longer than I intended but
there's just so much information I have
to cover plus I hit a couple of errors
but I really sometimes actually no one
really complains about the errors
anymore but just in case you're feeling
it inside you just didn't want to say
anything I do like to leave them because
these are errors like if I had an error
that like I'm like oh that's just me no
one else is possibly gonna hit that then
fine but these are all things that
you're gonna have because you're gonna
copy and paste this stuff you're gonna
forget that stuff you're gonna you're
just gonna keep making lots of errors
trust me so so hopefully you don't mind
that I'll leave them in there I think
they're pretty useful to leave in okay
so now what well first of all all this
stuff is going by really really slow the
slowest thing is actually you know
training this model it's very very slow
now if all you have available to you is
a low-end CPU or whatever or even a
high-end CPU but if all you have
available to you is a CPU that's okay
you can still follow along you can at
least train stuff so things start taking
steps at the very least but moving
forward from here I am going to assume
or I'm gonna use a GPU you can use
whatever you want but in the next video
I'm gonna show how we can convert this
code to be PI torch on the GPU code and
hopefully at least if you don't have
access to a GPU honestly lots of cloud
GPUs are pretty cheap there's also
google collab there's like a juror has I
guess credits I think if you have a an
edu address
I haven't confirmed this but apparently
you can get like $200 in credit if you
have a GP or a cheap uterus and edu
address but most places that will give
you credits won't allow you to
access the GPU so I could be mistaken
there because obviously people are gonna
like mine crypto and stuff so jerks ruin
it for everybody but anyway so there's
stuff like that
otherwise you can rent GPUs in the cloud
for pre cheap you don't need them for
very long so you rent them you use
whatever you need you spend like usually
like a dollar or something like that and
then you're done
so anyway that's what we're gonna talk
about in the next tutorial is just the
GPU version of pine torch and then we're
gonna get back to models but the models
and stuff that we're going to be doing
is gonna be kind of assuming you're
running on a GPU because the next thing
we want to do is like okay we got 64
percent accuracy now what well we
probably want to do more epochs of
training like 64 is good it's better
than you know random random would have
been 50% but you know so do we want to
train this for three more epochs and
after three epochs if we did better
should we continue should we do 666
thousand you know at what point do we
stop training and all that so we have to
talk about how to actually read the
statistics of our model maybe visualize
some things how to actually figure out
should I keep training should I not and
then maybe like if you want to change
models how do we compare models anyway
that doing that all that testing is what
takes up the bulk of your time and or at
least takes up the bulk of your GPU time
so this is just time where you're
sitting around doing nothing
so for that step for that research step
it's just way better to have a GPU so
that's what we're going to talk about in
the next tutorial and then after that
we're going to talk about visualization
and all that and just analyzing your
models so even if you don't have a GP or
you don't have access to them you can
just watch the next one if you want and
then after that you can still follow
along it's just things are gonna take a
lot longer to run for you than for us so
anyway that's all for now
shout out to recent channel members they
just brand new shiny channel members
Ralph Rodriguez David Lavoie AI
creations and Anand I'm gonna just call
you an on-demand login Nathan
I'm sorry if I mispronounced that feel
free to collect correct me below thank
you guys very much for your support it
allows me to make extra long videos just
like this one okay I will see you guys
in the next video